welcome to this video demo 05 demo 05
demrick Kerrigan yeah this is a carry
gun probably nothing nothing he says
gonna make me famous again I don't know
I'm plating before fifty fifty percent
famous I don't know I just play some
boring line now been a long long session
and simple chess is sometimes the way to
go okay is avoiding any kind of exchange
variations okay so let's let's try for
direct play on the queenside it's an
interesting moment your black can think
of a playing a for trying to block the
queenside for the cost of one pawn
bishop see 594 hmm otherwise I'm going
to gay is doing that it's an interesting
interesting pawn sacrifice this is
definitely sorry I'm definitely
something that is playable in a blitz
game maybe even in long and long time
control chess wow my voice is really
failing me sorry
so c5 txtx takes not just nice for wide
know
Jeff Oh interesting interesting so i can
take here take them what is the big
point of it what is the point I don't
don't get it I just have a protective s
on d5 and like it's just I don't don't
see anything here fine and can take you
fire famine mm-hmm ok before hangs
it still looks quite wrong but ok take
see 5 or not it's not really that great
of a ticket bishop is also attacking but
ok I really don't see if what else I
should do ok so 94 here this is a kind
of a self pin possible a bishop hang so
have to do something about it I just
takes it hmm it was stupid
well this applied you really really
badly from this probably have probably
very good position Quincy to evade
wasn't that clear I don't know Quincy to
it's not so easy to maintain control
that looks really weird but okay
yeah opposite colored bishops very often
increasing the drawing the drawing
tendencies not sure about this position
but ok for this is by the way equal
material right ok why he takes rook
takes it's a draw if it's not doing that
he's risking quite a lot I think I've
worked you 157 racine oh yeah this is
really just a dead drop yeah interesting
interesting I mean I don't know what was
going on there Bishop Bishop age 6 of a
kind of acute move so chair maybe night
c4 is better but this looked really good
a thought but probably not
yes as interesting game yeah this I mean
okay with Quincy to us is just quite
just very strong by concrete means this
hangs and this hangs I'm kind of my meta
centers crumbling so this wasn't the way
to go i was just looking at the static
thing there's this protected passer but
that's really not not that great I mean
I can play rook d1 or something Queen a2
I don't know something like that I
probably have to have to play something
like that I mean it looks nice for white
the computer is giving wider very high
score one point seven ER like winning
but it's it's still very very murky what
is notable is this this is pawn
sacrifice interesting interesting
possibility generally speaking this is
not a very good line from like this is
this kind of setup if he's not
sacrificing the porn which is like like
this for example then before takes gigs
let's say something like this is very
very nice for wide and I have not even
castle yet so it's not that he's got a
very quick attack on my king yeah Tim
I've got a pawn but it's not easy at all
before you had a caption hmm yeah yeah
the computer just loves white but it's
not so easy as we have as we have
witnessed yeah I mean cd6 looked really
okay but maybe maybe I can do something
else here
I a computer wants to take on f5 first
hmm but this is really not as good as
let's say even 94 I mean looks better I
mean just to show what I'm angling for
this kind of thing a five-week e4 week
this kind of thing is what what white
can get if he's playing it correctly but
I didn't ok well i hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching